6 13 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy how about a Labor Day
weekend travel question that's really
got nothing to do with the backed up
I-15 traffic around Primm
viewer Becky's questions about the
freeway in the other direction on that
little slice of Arizona between Nevada
and Utah will the I-15 construction
project South towards Mesquite still be
down to one lane over the holiday Ryan
Harding from the Arizona Department of
transportation's got the answer the
South half of the bridge is currently
being rebuilt so both directions of
traffic are sharing the north half of
the bridge with one lane in each
Direction now he adds once the South
half of the bridges rebuilt traffic will
shift to that side of the bridge while
the north half is demolished and rebuilt
the whole project set to be completed in
the summer of 2024.
yeah so those delays on the 15th with
the Virgin River Gorge can be upwards of
half hour you got to be prepared by the
way if you happen to pull over in the
small town of Littlefield nearby drop in
on the intergalactic bus stop and tell
Chris I said hello I think it's a story
for our George Knapp there buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight and
eightnewsnow.com hey Pastor can we
quickly go backtrack what the
intergalactic bus stop yeah should we
should we know more about this
I was reaching out to everybody I could
trying to get hold the Arizona
Department of Transportation for a
little bit more on that I-15 bridge
project and I'm looking around the
Google Map and there's The Intergalactic
bus stop and there's a phone number and
I call Chris and he goes yo it's not
just humans anybody can stop here
let me give you a heads up there's no
buildings there oh it's just a patch of
dirt
okay I will not be stopping thank you
Nate but there's a bunch of stuff in the
neighborhood it's definitely worth
checking out and if you meet Chris I
want to know more about him